three
two
one
[Music]
please welcome
the fabulous
[Music]
there's a certain feeling of adrenaline
once you get up there in the air
it's a feeling unlike any other
you feel
power you feel
like you're in control
you feel special
that's what makes trapeze beautiful
that's what makes the circus beautiful
[Music]
my name is kristen finley and i'm a
trapeze artist
15 years ago i was working for brewery
in los angeles
i had a great life making great money i
had you know my lexus and i had a house
i was only you know 24 years old
a friend of mine told me that she was
flying trippies and i said what are you
doing i want to come watch
i ended up taking a class
and i was hooked it was addictive
right away
and i quit my life in la and i joined
the circus
[Music]
i went from good pay to zero pay just
had to give everything up pretty much
overnight
and here we are 15 years later
i never looked back and i've been on the
road ever since
[Music]
to run away and join the circus it takes
commitment
you have to be ready for anything you
have to kind of
live on your toes because you never know
what's going to happen
your own personal space your rv or
whatever that's your home
and that's
what has to be stable inside
[Music]
whenever you're flying trapeze you have
to focus on what you're doing and the
moment you doubt yourself in the middle
of a trick most likely you're going to
mess up you're not going to make it
the fact that i was able to do it made
it more appealing to me i'm doing these
tricks and they're harder and they're
harder and this is awesome
whatever you want to do in your wildest
dreams do it
anything's possible there's not too many
african-american female circus
performers but i was still able to do it
your life is what you make of it and i
wouldn't change my life for the world i
really wouldn't
[Music]
you